A
MOB, FOR THAT MATTER.
POWER IS ALL THAT MATTERS.
HERE WITH MORE IS TEXAS
GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT.
THAT I RIGHTLY DESCRIBE THE BILL
IN YOUR STATE AND AM I RIGHTLY
DESCRIBING THE RESTRICTIVE
VOTING LAWS IN DELAWARE?
>> SEAN, I'VE HEARD THIS TOPIC
DISCUSSED AT LENGTH OVER THE
PAST FEW DAYS.
NO ONE ARTICULATED IT BETTER
THAN YOU JUST DID.
YOU PROVIDED THE BEST SUMMARY,
YOU GET A 10 OUT OF 10 ON YOUR
ENTIRE MONOLOGUE.
I WOULD HOWEVER ADD ONE THING TO
WHAT YOU SAID, BECAUSE YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT WHAT BIDEN HAS
BEEN SAYING AND BIDEN IS CALLING
PEOPLE NAMES AND YOU LEFT ONE
OUT.
YOU LEFT OUT THE FACT THAT BIDEN
CALLED ME A NEANDERTHAL FOR
OPENING TEXAS 100% AND
ILLUMINATING MASKS.
SO NOW I AM, BY BIDEN'S
ASSESSMENT, A NEANDERTHAL AND A
RACIST.
TO, BOTH OF WHICH ARE COMPLETE
THE WRONG.
WHAT'S GOING ON IN TEXAS WITH
REGARD TO THIS ELECTION WHILE WE
ARE TRYING TO PASS, AS YOU
POINTED OUT VERY PERFECTLY.
WE ARE ADDING HOURS TO VOTE.
IF NOT SUBTRACTING OURS TO VOTE.
EVERYTHING WE ARE DOING IS
PERFECTLY LEGAL.
THE ONLY OTHER THING I WOULD ADD
IS THE HYPOCRISY OF THE
DEMOCRATS FROM TEXAS, AS WELL AS
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., BECAUSE ONE
THING THE DEMOCRATS FROM TEXAS
ARE TRYING TO ACHIEVE IN
WASHINGTON, D.C., THEY ARE
TRYING TO GET THE UNITED STATES
SENATE TO DROP THEIR FILIBUSTER
RULE.
WELL, THINK ABOUT THIS.
WHAT THE TEXAS DEMOCRATS ARE
DOING, THEY ARE FILIBUSTERING IN
TEXAS TO TRY AND GET THE
WASHINGTON, D.C., DEMOCRATS TO
STOP A FILIBUSTER RULE.
THAT IS THE HEIGHT OF HYPOCRISY.
ALL THEY WANT TO DO IS COMPLAIN.
THEY WANT TO SPREAD FALSE
INFORMATION ABOUT -- I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU BASED ON WHAT YOU
SAID IN YOUR MONOLOGUE AS WELL
AS WHAT THE FACTS ARE, THERE IS
ZERO CHANCE THAT THE TEXAS LAW,
WHEN IT DOES GET PAST, WILL BE
OVERTURNED BY A COURT OF LAW,
BECAUSE WHAT WE'RE DOING IS
PERFECTLY CONSTITUTIONAL.
>> Sean: TALK ABOUT THE
COVERAGE OF PEOPLE SAYING THAT
YOU MIGHT HAVE THESE DEMOCRATS
ARRESTED WHEN THEY LAND BACK IN
TEXAS, ARRESTED FOR WHAT, UNDER
WHAT STATUTE?
>> SO WHAT THE LAW IS, BY
CONSTITUTION, THE HOUSE SETS THE
RULES ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS WHEN A
QUORUM IS BROKEN AND WHAT
HAPPENS IS THIS.
AND THAT IS ONCE A CALL ON THE
HOUSE HAS BEEN MADE, WHICH IT
HAS BEEN, THAN THE SERGEANT AT
ARMS OF REPRESENTATIVES CAN WORK
WITH THE TEXAS DEPARTMENT OF
PUBLIC SAFETY TO GO ARREST,
APPREHEND, WHATEVER WERE DOING
TO CHOOSE, AND BRING TO THE
CAPITAL THE MISSING HOUSE
MEMBERS WHO ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR
BREAKING A QUORUM.
THE ONLY LIMITATIONS ARE THAT,
SEAN, IS THAT THE JURISDICTION
LIMITS TO THAT ARE IN THE STATE
OF TEXAS, WHICH IS WHY THE TEXAS
LAW ENFORCEMENT IS NOT UP THERE
IN WASHINGTON, D.C., OR SOME
OTHER LOCATION TRYING TO PURSUE
THESE HOUSE MEMBERS.
SO HERE'S THE DEAL.
AS LONG AS THOSE TEXAS HOUSE
MEMBERS REMAIN IN WASHINGTON,
THEY SAY WE ARE NOT GOING TO
HAVE A QUORUM.
BUT KNOW THIS: A SPECIAL SESSION
IN TEXAS LAST 30 DAYS, ONCE THIS
30 DAY SPECIAL SESSION EXPIRES,
IF THE MEMBER'S RETURN, WILL
CALL ANOTHER ONE AND WE WILL BE
BACK IN SESSION UNLESS THEY
LEAVE AGAIN, IN WHICH CASE I
WILL CONTINUE CALLING SPECIAL
SESSION AFTER SPECIAL SESSION
AFTER SPECIAL SESSION, SO THEY
WILL HAVE TO BE GONE FOR THE
STATE OF TEXAS ALL THE WAY UP
UNTIL THE NEXT ELECTION.
[INDISCERNIBLE] --
>> Sean: [INDISCERNIBLE] MAYBE
THEY GET PAID [INDISCERNIBLE] --
GO AHEAD, SIR.
>> THIS IS THE POINT THE
DEMOCRATS HAVE NOT THOUGHT OF.
WHAT IS THEIR END GAME?
THEY HAVEN'T THOUGHT ABOUT THAT.
AND I CAN TELL YOU WHAT END GAME
IS.
WE ARE GOING TO HAVE A SPECIAL
SESSION WHERE THESE AND OTHER
ISSUES ARE GOING TO BE ON,
INCLUDING DOING A BETTER JOB OF
SECURING OUR BORDER, INCLUDING
CUTTING OUR PROPERTY TAXES IN
TEXAS.
INCLUDING HELPING OUR TEACHERS,
THEY WERE VOTED RELIEF TODAY BY
THE TEXAS SENATE BUT THEY ARE
NOT GOING TO GET IT BECAUSE THE
TEXAS HOUSE MEMBERS ARE NOT
THERE.
WE VOTED OUT OF THE TEXAS SENATE
TODAY PROPERTY TAX RELIEF THAT
THE PEOPLE OF TEXAS WILL NOT GET
BECAUSE THE DEMOCRATS WERE NOT
IN THE TEXAS HOUSE OF OUR
TENTATIVE'S.
SO THEY HAVE A JOB TO DO AND LET
ME TELL YOU SOMETHING.
TEXAS VOTERS ARE GOING TO BE
EXTREMELY ANGRY AT THE TEXAS
HOUSE MEMBERS FOR NOT SHOWING UP
AND NOT DOING THEIR JOB.
IF YOU DIDN'T SHOW UP AND DO
YOUR JOB AND OTHER PEOPLE WHO
ARE WATCHING A SHOW RIGHT NOW
DID NOT SHOW UP AND DO THEIR
JOB, THEY WOULD BE LOSING THEIR
JOB OR LOSING THEIR PAY.
THAT IS EXACTLY WHAT IS GOING TO
HAPPEN TO THE MEMBERS OF THE
TEXAS HOUSE OF REPRESENTATIVES.
>> Sean: SO IN OTHER WORDS,
IT'S NOT AN ARREST IN THE
TRADITIONAL SENSE, BUT TEXAS LAW
ALLOWS FOR LAW ENFORCEMENT TO
ESCORT THEM TO DO THEIR JOB,
WHICH IS MANDATED BY LAW, IS
THAT A CORRECT STATEMENT?
>> I WILL ADD TO IT.
SO THEY WILL BE BROUGHT TO THE
CAPITAL.
THEY WILL BE BROUGHT TO THE
TEXAS HOUSE CHAMBER AND THE
HOUSE CHAMBER DOORS WILL BE
LOCKED AND NO ONE CAN LEAVE
WITHOUT PERMISSION OF THE
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
>> Sean: LAST QUESTION.
I'M CONCERNED ABOUT THE
WEAPONIZATION OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE AS THE NEW
ATTORNEY GENERAL, MERRICK
GARLAND NOW IS GOING AFTER
GEORGIA THAT HAS FAR MORE
ACCESSIBILITY FOR VOTING THAN
JOE'S STATE OF DELAWARE, THAT
SEEMS TO ME LIKE THEY HAVE
WEAPONIZED OUR JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT AND WHY WOULDN'T THEY
GO AFTER THIS DATE WITH THE MOST
RESTRICTIVE LAWS LIKE JOE'S
STATE, BECAUSE HE NEVER LIFTED A
FINGER TO LIFT THE RESTRICTIONS
IN DELAWARE?
>> EXACTLY.
IT'S COMPLETELY HYPOCRITICAL.
ALSO AS YOU ARE POINTING OUT,
TEXAS HAS MORE VOTING HOURS AND
EARLY VOTING THAN DOES DELAWARE.
THE SAME IS TRUE IN TEXAS AS IN
THE STATE OF NEW YORK, FOR
EXAMPLE, BUT THERE'S NO CHANCE
THAT THE BIDEN DEMONSTRATION
WOULD GO AFTER DELAWARE OR
NEW YORK OR ANY DEMOCRAT STATE,
SO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
GETTING A FEEL FOR WHERE THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS, AND
THAT IS HOSTILE TO ANYTHING THAT
DOESN'T FIT THE SOCIALIST